You're probably wondering, by the title of this video,
Justine, what is the most expensive things at Starbucks
I'm sure there's probably something else
That might be more expensive,
But I haven't found it, and for me personally
This is the most expensive thing that
I've ever brought at Starbucks and let me tell you
Was it worth it?
Yes! Yes it was!
And yes, it is worth it.
This thing has brought me so much joy
Over the past couple weeks that I've had it
And it's been really difficult for me to keep it a secret
because It's been the only thing that I wanted to talk about.
I wanted to show it to you
I wanna post it on Instagram,
I wanna post it on Snapchat,
I wanna even post it on Facebook!
But I haven't.
Cause I've been saving it for this very video.
People have been to my house
And I'm like: Do not talk about the BIG, CUP.
We cannot address the 'Elephant in the room'
Which is not actually an elephant
We cannot address the fact that
I've got, this, sitting in my kitchen.
There is just the best
So now, everybody who wanna take a picture and post
this before, come back over.
You can post it now.
Let's talk about the story of why I purchased this.
It's quite a silly reason actually.
Mostly because I didn't think this is something that
I'm could purchase.
Because everytime I'm in a store, and
And I see something really cool, like this,
There's this huge Lego mini figure
That I saw, in the store,
And I asked to buy it and the guy was like:
That's not for sale.
(Slow motion) It's display only.
It's clearly on display to be purchased
And I'm willing to give you the money for the item.
Can I please have it?
God, this mini figure was so cool,
Like I still think about it.
Anyway. Back to the big cup at hand.
I was basically having like the worst week ever.
I shattered my phone, so many things had gone wrong.
In this week, and I was just like: (Sigh)
So while my phone is getting fix in the Apple Store,
I went to Starbucks, and I saw this up there,
on the display. Like that.
Sitting up on the shelf,
Very very high.
And I ordered my drink, and I...
I'm like: Yo. Is this thing for sale?
He said, well nobody has ever really asked me that
So, I don't think so. I guess, but why not?
I mean if it's on the shelf, we usually sell everything on the shelf.
So he asked me to look at the bottom,
If there's a skew number, then yeah
It was in fact for sale.
So I flip it over and I see $94.95
And I'm like
WHAT??
That's ridiculous. That's an absolute waste of money!
I need it.
I had so many plans just go through my mind of what I was going to do with this.
I'm going to walk around outside
I can't even pick it up with one hand unfortunately
Matt was able to pick it up with one hand but I can''t
I can't hold it straight.
So after I make all these silly videos
I'm probably going to put a plotted plant in it
Because it's basically the most perfect plant pot ever
I'd like to put maybe a tiny tree
Like a mini tree in it
I don't really know anything about mini trees...
Except that they're
small
The guy brings it up and it turns out it's actually only seventy three (73) dollars. It was on sale!
*not breathing* seventy three dollars for a cup
*still not breathing* what?!
*laughs*
*inhales* Yeah, OK sure I'll take it
And since my phone was broken and it was at the Apple Store, I wasn't logged in on my Starbucks app
So I didn't have my Starbucks app and I-I w-was like, "Well, I gotta get the stars for this purchase!"
So I had to re download the Starbucks app on my pixel phone and everything.
You know, long story short: It all worked out great
I got a lot of, a lot of points. I got a lot of stars
W-whatever.
The fact is, this cup fits on my head
Like this is on my head right now
*snaps*
It's very heavy
It's quite a substantial cup
I wonder how many cups of coffee would fit in here, does it say how many ounces?
It says for decoration only.
Awe :( *cri*
Starbucks coffee company in Seattle manufactured for Starbucks. 2016 All rights reserved
Made in China
*flips cup*
But like, look
There is a skew
So he said if there's a skew, I could buy it
And after I bought it, there was a huge opened spot on that shelf where this once belonged
Yeah, the guy was like, "No one's ever bought it, no one's ever asked to buy it and never... they just usually take pictures of it in the store."
So here comes crazy Justine
Knowing that this needs to be an item in her life
And it completely just turned that awful week, upside down, into a very very happy day
Let me tell you how funny it was
Me carrying this thing around the street
Trying to get it to my car
Because I didn't want to go in the apple store with it
And it's *quick pause* SO HEAVY!
So I was like carrying it like this
And I (was) like walking out of the store trying to carry this plus my purse and a-a full hot tea
This was, I was like this
It was so awkward
I was so 'fraid I was gonna drop it
Do you guys think this was a bad purchase?
Do you think it was?
I think it was worth it
I've already gotten so much joy
And so much entertainment out of it
That I think it was worth it
I can't wait to plant my plant
Do you guys have any suggestions for plants that I should plant because I don't know anything about plants or keeping them alive
Maybe a cactus
I should definitely, definitely plant a cactus
Because that'll stay alive
Well yeah that's it
That's the end of the story
I just wanted to show you guys my new big cup
And talk about *quick pause* money management
The dog doesn't really like it *laugh*
I kept trying to put treats in it
And he would just be like.. then run the other way
Let me know what you guys think of my cup
Let me know if you have any funny things that you would like to see me do with the cup
I think that I would like to fill it up with coffee
And try to drink it
All?
That's not safe
Don't do that, that's a bad idea
We'll see you guys later, hope you guys have a great day
Um, click like if you like big cups and you cannot lie *laughs*
OH GOD, I'm here all day
I'll see you guys later
Bye!
This is so great, IM SO HAPPY!
So this is what it looks like.
I can't even turn around because I'm in such a tight space.
What'd it, How's it look?
From the back.
Does it look good?
They both fell out.
I mean the good news is, Oh gosh.
I mean Iguess the good news is if they fall out